Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call where I do my best to answer questions that you submit.
If you're out here and you think of a question, you can chat it in.
So just in the chat box, just type in your question and we'll get to that probably after we get through the questions that were submitted.
So as a reminder, you'll see announcements on the members homepage.
I do have an announcement for next week that I'll put up there that we won't have a Zoom call next week because it's Christmas.
But I think I'm going to have one of New Year's. So, you know, we don't go two weeks without a Zoom call.
I've never got two weeks without a Zoom call.
I think in this, seven and a half years doing this, I think we miss seven Zoom calls now because I'm traveling.
And I remember this fall, so we don't want to miss two weeks in a row.
So I'll probably do what I do is you're, I don't know what he will probably be on, but at least we'll record it with your questions and you guys can listen to it.
Also, another announcement, this screenshot of this announcement, this slide is an old one.
You'll see an announcement as YouTube is.
Gosh, we got two videos taken down by YouTube last week.
There are because, you know, you mentioned cancer or something on YouTube.
This was somebody asked a question about MMS and they don't allow anybody talking about MMS.
Of course, you can have all sorts of launching stuff on YouTube.
But if you mentioned anything about natural healing, they nail you.
So, they, you know, I understand it's just an AI bot on YouTube doing this, but it is a pain.
We got two videos taken down and we had two.
So the Zoom calls are not going up on YouTube for now.
So you've got to find the Zoom calls on our video site.
And I do have information on the, on the member site, both the home page of the member site and on the Zoom call page of the member site showing the link to our video site.
Where you can find the Zoom calls.
And then when you go to our video site, just search Zoom.
See right up each Zoom call is titled Zoom and then the date in this format.
So you can just search for Zoom and the date in this format.
And you'll see most of the, you'll see that all the Zoom calls.
We're doing is we're chopping up the Zoom call questions into small videos and posting them in our member site and posting them on the video site so that you can find if you just search for something specifically.
I've tried to find your question or trying to find a question about.
Like you've got a question about Fennband is all on this.
Questions tonight. So if you're looking for something on Fennband is that you could start typing it in.
It's a nice search.
Function on the video site.
So you could search for Fennband is all you can find.
You know, I've done.
Answered multiple questions about Fennband is all over the year. So you'll be able to find that.
Also remember you could self schedule follow up calls.
If you need to have a call directly with me at any time as well.
Okay, let's get to the questions.
Oh, it's the first question.
Oh, of course, because it's the one I looked at.
Can you refresh my memory on the Fennband is all or Joe Tippins protocol?
So I don't know if anyways ever heard of that.
I mean, I'm sure some of you have heard of that but Joe Tippins was a,
is just a lay person, not a doctor who was told who was told that he had only months or something to live with lung cancer and then his.
Friend who was a veteran area or something told him to do Fennband is also Fennband is all is.
A dog and cat D were mean medication can be purchased over the culture.
We have it in our store.
It is in powder form typically for a dog or cat because you'd sprinkle it on their food and then they would just eat it.
And it helps with the were mean.
Now, Fennband is all works in similar ways as Ivermectin.
So everybody's heard of Ivermectin.
Ivermectin and Fennband is all are good for cancer, not because of their anti parasitic function, but because they work on different metabolic pathways.
It has been found that both Fennband is all and Ivermectin help increase the P53 tumor suppressor genes.
So remember you have two or suppressor genes in every cell.
And they are meant to turn on if a cell becomes the cancer cell meaning that if the cell has a damaged nucleus and goes into rapid replication.
Then it's supposed to turn on the tumor suppressor system.
Now you have multiple different tumor suppressor genes.
The P53 are probably the most researched tumor suppressor genes.
They were the first ones discovered.
So there's more research on the P53 probably than anything.
There's certain things that can suppress our tumor suppressor system.
So when the tumor suppressor genes turn on, they help to cause the cell to implode by stimulating what's called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
It's a certain mechanism that turns on.
I actually have some videos on how that actually works.
The intrinsic apoptotic pathway is called apoptosis 101, 201, 201 or something like that.
I have several videos on that.
But to show this up, the tumor suppressor genes are supposed to kick it and it causes the cell to die.
You never have a diagnosis of cancer.
The truth is, this is happening all the time in all of us.
Even if you have a cancer diagnosis, maybe you have breast cancer.
Well, there's a good chance that you know, cancer is starting in your liver.
Totally separate, maybe hepatic cancer or in your colon or in your ovaries or in your, you know, whatever.
And you're, it's something damage that cell, it starts to go into rapid replication.
Your tumor suppressor genes kick in and P53 genes are one of those tumor suppressor genes.
Then it causes intrinsic apoptotic pathways to be stimulated.
The cell line is destroyed and you never knew you had cancer, quote unquote.
So remember, cancer in order to be diagnosed has to be well over three million cells large.
And usually by the time a cancer is diagnosed, it's tens and millions of cells large.
And then it's diagnosed as a cancer.
So this, you know, the, the saying that we all have cancer is true.
But our body is doing adequate job of keeping it in a bay.
So it never gets to the point of being diagnosed.
You might say, well, I love this call because I have been diagnosed with cancer.
So my tumor suppressor gene must stink or something like that.
Not necessarily your tumor suppressor gene might be doing a wonderful job of keeping all sorts of cancers at bay.
But in the instance of the particular cancer you have.
So let's use an example of I have breast cancer right now.
Well, when did it start?
Well, I was diagnosed last, last May pretend.
Okay, well, when did it start?
Well, it probably started several years before that.
One cell large to begin with.
And then some damage to the nucleus.
And now it starts doubly tripling.
And maybe it's three million cells large in nine months.
And then it's still you can't feel it in your breast.
And maybe a year later now, you could palpate it.
You what's the doctor got a biopsy, blah, blah, blah.
Not diagnosed.
So how did that happen in the first place?
Well, certainly your tumor suppressor gene didn't adequately function at that given time when that started in your breast at that given time.
And there could be all sorts of reasons why not there can be different things that can suppress your tumor suppressor genes.
So remember, tumor suppressor genes, you want those functioning properly in order to kill a growing cancer.
What could suppress your tumor suppressor genes?
Well, stress is one thing that can suppress your tumor suppressor genes.
If I'm under a lot of stress at that given time, that can be that can overwhelm my tumor suppressor system.
If I had a lot of cells damaged at the same time, let's say I received a dose of radiation from, I don't know, I mean, I have no idea.
But pretend I had a, you know, okay, there's an example of somebody who went under wet radiation therapy for a breast cancer.
And then they ended up with a melanoma on the skin.
Well, it's because they had so much damage because of that radiation that it overwhelmed their tumor suppressor gene.
And the cancer started growing.
And this is why we tell you not to be taking a lot of methyl groups as a cancer patient.
Because methyl groups, excess methyl groups and methyl comolubite and methyl folate can overwhelm, can, can silence tumor suppressor genes and can cause a cancer to start growing.
So there's lots of other things that could, that could suppress your tumor suppressor system.
You could have defects on your tumor suppressor genes.
That's why we look at those when we look at your genetics.
So long story to say, well, how does ventmenazole, the question was really asked about the protocol.
But I kind of wanted to overview of how ventmenazole and iburemactyl actually work.
They actually upregulate the tumor suppressor system.
So when a person has cancer, and if you could upregulate the tumor suppressor system,
then you could effectively stimulate apoptosis from the inside out.
So you're stimulating the intrinsic apoptonic pathway in a cell in, in stimulating cancer death.
That's all curcubid works. That's why pulmonary works. That's how a lot of the natural therapies work for cancer as well.
They, there's multiple pathways and how they work.
So there's also multiple pathways, however, vector and ventmenazole work.
But I, I find upregulation of the P53 pathway, most intriguing.
So back to the question.
Could you refresh my memory and the ventmenazole?
Showtip into protocol.
Now, I'll put this up.
We actually had a really nice, I'm asking Angie where it is.
We had a really nice document that was an infographic on the,
the joke tip in this protocol.
But again, the power is at B. We got a eight page letter from the FDA.
Remember I talked about it a few years ago.
It was probably a year and a half ago where it, like, scared the ebgb's out of here
that they're going to throw you in prison tomorrow.
If you don't take all the Joe Tipins information and the ventmenazole information off of our website.
So we had to take all of that off of our website.
The things we struggle with on a fairly regular basis.
This is why I tell people we cherish your prayers because the powers at B.
AKA the pharmaceutical industry.
That is controlling basically all of our government doesn't want these cures to be known.
So we had to take it off of our website.
And the whole internet was scrumbed of ventmenazole slash dope Joe Tipins information.
Now people have courageous, they put more stuff up there and we started to put stuff up there again.
But just waiting for another letter from the FDA.
So anyhow, I have a nice infographic of what the Joe Tipins protocol is.
Typically it is the starting protocol for the ventmenazole protocol is one packet,
which is 222 milligrams of ventmenazole, which is equivalent, which you'd give a 10 pound dog.
So it's not very much.
It's a pretty low dose of ventmenazole.
So it's a one packet per day and you're only taking it three to four days per week.
So you can put it in your smoothie and it's really tasteless.
And then you're taking curcumin with it, burberry with it, vitamin E with it,
which is our apop E, and then typically you're taking CBD with it.
So I'll put that protocol up on the member site.
Can anybody add the ventmenazole protocol to their protocol?
Or Ivermectin.
And Ivermectin, I did put the protocol because somebody asked the question last week or the week before about that.
I did put that either the dosage protocol up on the member site homepage for everybody.
Can anybody add those two things?
Yes.
The only thing that I ask that you do, if you do add that, is to get at least monthly a complete metabolic panel, which would be, which would show liver markers.
Because we don't want it to, whatever you're taking a medication, it can overwhelm your liver.
Most people it doesn't, but it can.
And I don't want it to spike your ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase.
So we want to keep an eye on those markers.
If you're fun, if it's not doing anything to that, I've been on it for a month, and I did my labs, and it's there completely within normal limits.
They were saved what they were three months before when I wasn't on this.
Then maybe you could spread it out to every two months, but we want to keep an eye on your liver markers to make sure that it's there's no issues with your liver.
That was a long answer for that question.
I apologize. Next question.
When taking, oh, same question.
I remember back then, if Fennbenzal, did they need to be taken at the same time, or can I take one in the morning and the other at lunch?
No, you don't need to take them at the same time.
So Fennben is usually an abbreviation for Fennbenzal.
So you do not need to take them at the same time.
I would suggest you split them up.
So taking one in the morning, one at lunch, or one in the morning, one in the evening, I think is a great idea.
So in the message, she found the information.
So we'll put the information.
She sent me the documents. We'll get it up on the member site for the Fennbenz documents.
In your opinion, do you think my MRI findings show that I should do something more drastic like radiation?
Would you need to see the actual images to make that opinion?
And if so, would I get the images?
Should I get the images to you? Thank you.
So this is a person who showed metastasis to the bone.
And the real question is when would I recommend radiation, or at least looking into doing radiation when you have metastasis to bone?
And the answer would be when you have one or two or three sites where there's a lot of damage, where there could be pathological fracture, or you have a lot of pain that is coming from that site.
If you have a speckled, which is a radiographic term, if you have a speckled distribution of litig lesions, which radiographically they would say that there's just a broad band speckled distribution of lesions throughout the spine or something like that that makes some kind of comment like that.
Then no radiation really isn't in the order.
So radiation is something you would do if you had like, you know, destruction of the L5 vertebrae, the 5th Lombard vertebrae, or where there's, you know, it's concentrated and there's in one or two spots.
And it's a weight-barried bone and or it is causing the person a lot of pain.
So radiation can be beneficial there.
When it's throughout the whole spine and the person doesn't have specific pain in any areas of the spine, maybe they just have generalized fatigue or aching or something like that in the spine, then radiation probably would not even be offered by the radiologist.
So that's I think that helps answer the question if you that doesn't just feel free to ask more depth.
Next question, I have an Atelier Robin rife machine. Should I add the foot bath apparatus? No, I don't recommend that because the Atelier Robin rife machine allows you to do the higher frequencies that royal rife actually used for cancer patients with the bulb or the true rife doesn't.
You can only get up to about 10 to 12,000 hurts with the royal rife where you can get up to 30,000 with the Atelier Robin. So you really don't need the foot bath.
Where the iron pro wave for the true rife came in is that you could do those higher frequencies with the iron pro wave that you couldn't do with the bulb with the plasma bulb with the Atelier Robin.
You don't need that because you can do those higher frequencies with the bulb, which I think is superior. So anything you can do with light. I think it's much better than doing with the foot bath anyhow. So we don't recommend I personally don't recommend the foot bath apparatus.
We have some people that have it and they're just like, I just want to do a foot bath. But it's not something that the reason why we recommend the foot bath with the true rife is to get those higher frequencies. Well, that's a no point with the Atelier Robin.
Next question. Is the clear inflame a good anti-inflammatory supplement for general pain? Yes. So the clear inflame I think is the best single shocked anti-inflammatory that we have.
Because it's a broad spectrum flavonoid meaty that it has tumeric baswellia, rosemary, corsetin, I don't know. So several other things in it. So it's got a broad spectrum of the flavonoids that are anti-inflammatory.
Now there are there are other possible anti-inflammatory supplements like the limit list, the aloeville limit list, which is a manel in supplement, which is highly anti-inflammatory. But it's only got that one thing in it.
But some people have used that and replaced taking an anvil. We're taking an anvil every day for their pain and now they just take that and it solves their problem. But from a general broad spectrum perspective, the clear inflame is probably the best product we have for pain.
Now understand you have pain from cancer that is fairly high on the pain scale level. The natural flavonoids or the betelins probably aren't going to do the trick.
So if you are currently taking multiple anvil during the day or you're currently on a prescription pain medication, the chance that you're going to get off of that by going on a flavonoid is slim.
Now I will say that I've had people on the clear inflame and they're on like five a day and then that's a negative because there's a lot in each capsule. You got to take a lot of capsules because there's a lot of different things in each capsule. You have to take a lot of capsules to get at a real treat with dose.
You're not taking an opening six pounds, you know, it's all in one which is a nice benefit. But I've had people taking six a day and it's not touching it and they move up to nine a day and it's like, oh my gosh, my pain's gone. So you've got to play with that dose.
And how do I know if this is going to work for me? Well, you don't unless you try it. Now the clear inflame is, you know, we originally got that private label.
For inflammation in the brain and, you know, if you watch my brain inflammation video, you'll find that all the research on brain inflammation and microglial primate and brain having neural antibodies to upper motor neuron tissue, we need brain tissue.
The only thing in all the research that decreased brain inflammation was the flavonoids. So that is, I mean, to prevent, you know, to prevent Alzheimer's to prevent, you know, any early dimension to prevent Parkinson's clear inflame is a key product.
So it's a product that I take on a regular basis and, you know, it's, it's, it can help beyond just pain. So hopefully that helps.
Next question. When running my rife day program, there are times I can't sit and finish the entire program. What should I do?
Well, it's same as running your night program. Let's say your night program is nine hours long and you have to get up and go to work. It's, you know, the only red at seven hours. Well, just turn it off and you'll get it tomorrow or those, how I write the night programs is they recycle throughout the night. You know, they're not just
you know, what was in the, in the later part of the program on Monday night might be an earlier part of the program Tuesday night. So you're not going to miss those frequencies.
The only times we've really shortened up people's night program is when they were like, okay, this is you got them at these are night hour programs that I never have been bad for more than five hours, you know, or some crazy thing like that.
You should be sleeping more than five hours. So I can shorten them up, but of course, when you shorten things up, you're getting less time per frequency, which is a good.
Now, the day programs, they're not recycled in there. So let's say it's a two hour day program and you're only getting an hour of it.
Well, then you're just going to get an hour of it that at this time and you just will maybe next time you'll be able to do the whole thing. So that's okay. So just do which can the day programs again are not required nothing's required, but the day programs are just for when you are
sitting and and have a chance to sit relax, you know, I tell people to try to create an environment at home where you can do the right.
When you're sitting watching TV or reading the book or something like that too. So you're getting as much right time as possible.
Can I stock taking the aroma clear when I start taking the aroma taste inhibitor medication. So aroma clear sounds like aroma taste, right.
So it's an aroma taste inhibitor supplement that has dim and a few other things in it that help all bad astrogens out of your body. So it's meant to be a quote unquote substitute for an aroma taste inhibitor medication.
So if you're in an aroma taste inhibitor medication, do you need to take dim or aroma clear or you know other natural aroma taste inhibitors.
No, you don't. I mean, the medication that's going to pull your hormones, your estrogens out of your body is going to far exceed what the nutritional approach will do.
That's why people like the nutritional approach, but you certainly don't need to spend money taking the aroma clear if you're going to be on the aroma taste inhibitor medication, then just put it in the fridge and save it for when and if you ever go off of that.
Next question, I have the Atelier Robin rife machine. When should I do the 11th harmonic frequencies you gave me, what are they for? So the 11th harmonic frequencies are really for kill programs.
So if you're running a viral program, if you set it at the 11th harmonic, it will run the frequency plus the 11th harmonic, which is 11 times that frequency.
There's been data that show that when you run 11 times the frequency, which is called the 11th harmonic with programs meant to kill cancer or kill bacteria or kill pathogens of any kind, you'll have a much higher kill rate.
So that's another reason why I like the Atelier Robin is that you can run the 11th harmonic and you can't do that with the true right.
So when do you run that? Well, with people that have the Atelier Robin, I write your program, you'll see a folder with your AA, your name, and then ARR, that's just your normal cancer program.
And then you'll see a your name 11th, that's your program in the 11th harmonic. The reason why I give you two folders is because I don't, I don't know if you'll get, I mean, you could effectively kill too quickly.
And we've seen this with the true right with people with Lyme disease. If you run a Lyme program, you could kill, you'll kill that bacteria.
But you could, by killing a bacteria, especially a gram negative bacteria, too quickly, you will, you will produce a lot of what are called endotoxins.
So an endotoxid is the end result of that cell death. When it's a gram negative bacteria, you're going to produce a lot of waste.
And with the gram negative bacteria, they have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membrane, and that can be overwhelming and difficult to detoxify.
So if you produce too many lipopolysaccharides from gram negative bacteria, that could be unhealthy, because that could damage your blood barrier.
So we always, you know, we don't have any Lyme patients on this call, because this is cancer call, but would we program for a true right for or actually a robin, which I haven't done yet for a Lyme patient, but for the true right when we programmed for a Lyme patient, I would have very short kill programs where we start off at only 15 minutes a day and go up to 30 and 60 and then a couple hours.
So then they'd have one overnight program because if you kill too quickly, you'll listen a lot of endotoxins while we don't know what's going to happen with cancer patients with the 11th harmonic, because this is the first time a machine has allowed you to do that no other machine of the market allows you to do that.
So when we write the cancer program with the 11th harmonic, if it kills too quickly, you might feel yucky the next day.
And I don't want you just to feel yucky all the time, so you might want to alternate the 11th harmonic program with your a your name, a our program, you know, every other night.
I mean, if you do it and you don't feel I don't feel like I want this to kill my cancer, I feel fine, I'm not feeling like my, I'm like I feel foolish or anything.
You'd get like a herkseimer type reaction where you'd feel kind of yucky than a headache, maybe, foolish, we don't want to go too quickly, so then we wouldn't do that.
Now, I also created the 11th harmonic frequencies for the most common pathogens.
So I created programs with the 11th harmonic for the most common pathogens like the 11th harmonic viral program with the true right.
If you got a viral complex program, it works great while it's going to work a lot better when you run it with the 11th harmonic.
Now, again, you can't do that with the true right, but you can with the utility robin.
So people that have the utility robin that have a folder with 11th harmonic kill pathogen kill programs that they can run for if they feel like a cold coming out or strep or some it's got a bunch of pathogens.
A pathogen is a bacteria fungus, a mold, a virus.
So you can run those at any time if you feel like something's coming out of the COVID or something like that, you can run the 11th harmonic COVID program.
But for your cancer program, you could start running those and if you have no ill effect of them, then you could keep running just that folder of your weekly set.
You may never do the a your name are set because you feel fine doing the 11th harmonic set, which I think is going to be superior.
But if you feel ill doing that, then switch back to the other set.
And if that was all very confusing, then just schedule call with me and I'll try to explain it. Maybe I'll create a video about that.
Next question, thinking of getting a second rife, can I buy the new one? Well, the new one is what we just described. So yes, that is an option.
We have a number of people that have two rife machines, one further bedroom, one for downstairs to use during the day or whether watching TV, that's where their TV is or whatever.
If you're thinking of doing that, I would get the Atelier Robin. If you even if you already have a true rife and I'll create just what I was talking about for you.
So just call the clinic and talk to Marie. How many times a week can I do a sauna, also how long and 10 and what 10 I think they're at.
So you can actually do a sauna. I think you could do a sauna every day.
So, now again, I think if you've never done a sauna and you just got a sauna, I think you have to work up to that.
So like anything, you could overdo it right away and you could feel really icky and so you got to just be careful in that.
But if you have a sauna and you've done it before and you like it, then start doing it. You could do once a day. How long? I wouldn't go more than 30 minutes.
And if you're new to doing a sauna, you might only be able to do 10 minutes. Don't like, I'm going to sit in here. I'm going to force myself to do 30 minutes.
No, no, personally, you know, I have the sauna that zips up in your head sticks out. I haven't done it since last winter.
It's about time to do it again, which was to have five inches of snow tomorrow.
So it's kind of sauna weather, but I seem to not tolerate more than 20 minutes. I got to get on it there.
Maybe it's just my OCD, ADHD character, but I, it feels wonderful for the first 15 minutes that I kind of struggled through the last five minutes.
And I like out here and I'm done in 20 minutes. Everybody's different. So don't think that there's a magic number. You got to do 30 minutes.
And then what temp typically we recommend 140. I have some people that might comment, I'm doing 160. I do one set. Typically it's 140 that you start with.
Can you go over the sides on a blood test that may indicate the test is to bone.
So, so on a standard blood test, you have a standard blood test would be that you go in and do an annual blood test. You're doing a CBC with a different shell.
I mean, that's your white blood cell, right, red blood cell, and a different shell of white blood cells to neutrophils lymphocytes, blah, blah, blah.
And then there's nothing really on there that show any signs of the test system. It's the complete metabolic panel, which is a standard blood test.
A complete metabolic panel is going to show your liver markers and your chloride and your calcium and your CO2.
So, what is a sign? Remember, blood tests are just signs. They're like, they're like little indicators. They don't tell you exactly what's going on, but they give you clues and you compare it to other things.
With what would be clues to the test system, if you already have a diagnosis of cancer, you would look for an elevated alcohol and phosphatase, with usually spared AST and ALT.
So, typically, AST, ALT and alcohol and phosphatase are considered liver markers, except ALT and phosphatase are also produced by bode, produced by your liver, it's produced by your intestinal tract, it's produced by, if you're pregnant, your placenta.
So, but if your alcohol and phosphatase is elevated, and your AST is within normal limits, and your ALT isn't within normal limits, and your calcium is elevated, that's a big clue that there may be metastasis to bode.
And I've talked to people on the phone that say, well, though I had a PET scan, you know, two months ago, it was normal. Well, again, there has to be, you know, fairly large, you know, has to be three million cells large before it's going to be seen on a PET scan, you can pick clues up by that.
If I had an oral PET scan three months ago, but now my alcohol and phosphatase is elevated, and my calcium is elevated, I'd have some concerns, and I may want to investigate.
So, remember, they're just clues to signal an investigation.
So, there's other reasons. So, if a person doesn't have a billed diagnosis of cancer, so let's say they're just going to for a regular workup, they don't have cancer, and they had elevated calcium levels.
First thing you think of is parathyroid tumor, not a thyroid tumor, but a parathyroid gland tumor. Very, it's actually quite common.
And the treatment for it is to remove the parathyroid glands, because the parathyroid tumor is going to cause an elevated calcium.
Now, what else can cause an elevated calcium? Well, with bony destruction will cause an elevated calcium.
So, if I have cancer diagnosis, and sometimes people don't know they have a cancer, and they find out when they already have metz to the bone, I didn't find out I had cancer until I had metz to the intestinal tract, the colorectal area.
But, so it's not a common that you don't know you have cancer, and tell your stage 4, you already have metastasis.
And it isn't all a totally a common that you don't know you have cancer until you find out you have metastasis to the bone.
So, that would be a clue if you don't have cancer, or you don't know you have cancer, or certainly if you know you have cancer, you have an elevated alkaline phosphatase with a spared AST and a spared ALT in an elevated calcium level.
Because cancer that metastasis to bone will be lidic, so it'll be it'll cause destruction of bone.
Oh, now I'll ask what does no zoom call next week on Christmas. Okay, it took a long time. All right, get to your questions.
I haven't done my foot bath in a long time. I did it two days ago and felt sick afterwards. I felt my throat had a feeling of sickness.
I felt like metal detox that I've had in the past. Now I feel like my lungs are struggling, et cetera, should the foot bath have put the foot bath have stimulated this.
Certainly, it could have certainly it could have just been a coincidence too.
But if you if you feel that way, okay, so that could be technically what's called a Herkseimer reaction, a Herkseimer reaction was first described by a doctor, Dr. Herkseimer German doctor.
And since then you might know lime people with a Lyme disease refer to it often because they many times inadvertently think that they're having a Herkseimer reaction, but they're actually having an autoimmune reaction, but that's another story.
So herkseimer reaction is when you kill too quickly and or you and you're liberating a lot of endotoxins, which is endotoxins are toxins from a destruction of a cell line.
That's happens in doing chemo because chemo is killing that through apoptosis but killing through pathological cell death of necrosis or lysis and you're liberating endotoxins.
You're liberating the cell membrane and all sorts of lysosomes and all the ribosomes and the innards of the cell that your liver now has to detoxify.
Same thing I said, when you kill bacteria, you're going to liberate endotoxins, you kill bacteria that are grabbed negative, you're going to liberate the polysaccharides, and you're going to have to detoxify that.
So seriously, if you do a foot bath and you feel that way, what does it sign up? If it is from that, it's a sign of clogged or overwhelmed liver detox pathways.
So do a coffee animal. So if you ever have a, you feel like you're having a herkseimer reaction, what is the treatment?
Drink a lot of water, do a coffee animal. Okay, here's another example. I went and got a massage. I never get a massage. I haven't got a massage for years.
I went and got this deep tissue massage for an hour and I felt like I was going to die the next day. I felt sick.
It's because you liberated all these toxins that was overwhelmed in your liver. What would be the treatment? Drink a lot of water.
That's why your massage therapist would say the same thing. Get a massage, just drink a lot of water, flush these things out.
Drink a lot of water, do a soda, would be another thing, do a coffee animal, do a hot pack over your liver or a castor oil with a hot pack over your liver.
Help support your detoxification pathways. And if you need help understanding that you guys all have access to my seven phases of detoxification course.
So go back and review the seven phases of detoxification. Are you constipated? Make sure that you're not constipated. Take some super aloe if you're constipated to unclog yourself.
Make sure you're having good moments. Make sure you're binding stuff in the gut and make sure you are supporting the liver in the bile duct.
You could have a clogged blocked bile duct. You could have a full gallbladder. And that's where hot packs over that area, castor oil packs over the liver, gallbladder area and coffee animals come in fashion.
So make sure you're supporting all the phases of detoxification. If it lasts more than a couple days, it's probably something else and you probably have a virus because typically a detox reaction.
It's typically a detox reaction. Sometimes they're called herxymory reaction is the most common name for them is only in the last a day or so. So if it's lasting more than you probably is just coincidental and you probably have a virus or something. So that's one way to know.
I slept with my true right tube tucked in next to me during the night under the covers with me. The tube gets quite warm and may even say it's hot. Is this normal? Yep. It is. It's normal.
Sometimes if you fall asleep like if I fall asleep, but it's just kind of jammed up next to me and the covers are there. It get very warm.
That's normal. You're not going to burn yourself hot, but you might want to try to give it a little more air. Is there a big advantage to drinking greens first throughout the day?
I've taken to mixing it in the morning and using it to wash down my morning supplements and finishing it. I'll stop if that's not good.
So there's a lot of nutrients in greens first. And if you're just taking it in the morning, remember, I don't think that's wrong. So I wouldn't say you should stop doing that.
But remember all your supplements, any supplements you take in any nutrients you get from food have a half light. So if you're taking everything, you're supposed to be taking it in the morning and you're not taking anything all day long.
So that stuff is all gone from you and it's doing you no good by the end of the day. So can it be good? The years ago, I used to have people when I give them the recipe for the drink. I'd say you have to sip it all day long.
The problem is people would just complain about that. It's getting warm. I don't like it. I forgot to finish it. I don't necessarily say that anymore.
But I think it's, it would be good to maybe swallow all your supplements with water and then have your green drink that you take a few hours to consume.
I just know that doesn't fit everybody's lifestyle. So when I make a great drink, it's usually gone within a half an hour. But I, there's no way I can, I just too much of a pig. I think I don't know.
I'm not sure if my lesions are speckled because you get that from the MRI findings. I looked at your MRI a couple weeks ago. So I, I just remember that they were diff, it was diffuse. I could be wrong. I'll look at that again tomorrow, though. So send me an email if you need to remind me.
You don't need to send me the images. Well, let me look at what the radiologist said. And then I'll email you tomorrow. There are a lot of new products out there, both supplements and topical, including peptides.
Do you know anything about them and whether they are helpful for cancer or particularly more effective than other supplements taken for some ailment like glucose metabolism, for example.
So peptides are the latest thing. I think, you know, I do know that there's, I know the Reordinate Clinic got into using peptides that I think they kind of faced out of that.
They were really big a couple years ago and injectable peptides are still big, but they were really big a few years ago.
And there's dangers in that with cancer because it can stimulate growth. Most of the peptides out there are for the purpose of stimulating growth.
So they're really used most commonly for athletic people and people that are in sports and people that have athletic injuries. So injectable peptides in joints and such to repair joints more quickly because they stimulate growth.
Well, that's obviously a giant red flag when you come to cancer care, but I do know that there are some different peptides that are available that don't do that.
And I'm just still really leery of the that because none of it's done specifically with cancer in mind. They're really it's really being pushed for other reasons.
So, there's remember a lot of things that you would do for your heart or for, you know, muscle issues or for repair of joint or for repair of the dot would be absolute no nose for cancer.
So because a lot of those things the way they work is to stimulate regeneration of cell lines, which is speed up metabolic pathways for growth, which can certainly help for cell lines and things that will stimulate
that Jeff production in your heart, your vascular endothelial growth factor to stimulate growth of vessels for cardiovascular issues, fantastic for heart issues, really bad for cancer patients.
So that's where, you know, some people go, I'm going to my, you know, I get this a lot with on case reviews, you know, additional calls I have with people.
I feel like I'm really comfortable with the supplements that I'm taking for my naturopath or my chiropractor or my doctor who you're my functional doctor.
And then I look at them and I go, you may want to reconsider this one, reconsider this one, reconsider this one.
You know, everything you learned in functional medicine, everything you learned in naturopath, the everything you learned in nutrition courses and a chiropractic, you know, education, do not equate to what you would do if you have cancer.
So in many of them should be, you know, there's no way you should do with cancer.
So, so you, you just got to be careful with that.
So, so I tried to, you know, I just put in my two cents, people couldn't throw it out and not listen to me.
But on the case of you, I just want to help people whether they start with us or not, I just want to, you know, let them know the reasoning behind things.
So, I think peptides fall into that. I wouldn't do them.
Sounds like there are a lot of positive attributes for the atelier rabid rifasheed, higher frequencies, live with harmonic.
I have a true rifasheed. What determines which particular rifasheed you choose for each particular patient?
Well, when you started and when most people listening to this started with us, the atelier rabid didn't exist.
So, the atelier rabid is a new rifasheed. And again, the atelier rabid has just been out the last couple of months.
So, again, I've told people throughout all of my practice for 35 years that I will never make recommendations based upon my loyalty to a company.
I'll only make recommendations based upon my loyalty to my patients.
So, you know, I've been asked to be part of different companies, different nutritional companies, different therapy companies throughout the years.
And I have to respectfully decline because what if something better comes along that I would make recommendations for, but then I'm financially tied to a company.
So, I've never wanted to be financially tied to a company. I want to be tied to my patients well-being and make only recommendations based upon what's best for the patients.
Now, you know, the true rif was bought out recently and they're making changes for the better.
A lot of people think that some changes are not for the better.
That's a matter of opinion. I think there may be some truth in some of that. I still think the true rif are fantastic machines.
Would I trade in my true rif for the atelier rabid? No, I wouldn't.
If I was going to buy another machine right now, what would I buy? The atelier rabid.
I think the atelier rabid is superior. And when true rif hears me say that, they're going to probably be really mad at me because I've been a big purchaser of them.
But if somebody came to me today and said, which machine should I buy? I'm going to say the atelier rabid.
If they came to me today and said, I really wanted true rif because my sister had a true rif and she got better.
I'm not going to argue with them. Let's get you a true rif then.
So I don't have any qualms about selling a true rif and supporting true rif and continuing to support true rif moving forward.
And I think they're great machines and they're, you know, they're, they're, I think now the second best machine on the market.
Just like what I was just doing true, I've, I also, we're also selling GB 4000.
And if person came to us with the GB 4000, we tried to help them to problem with the GB 4000. They're not programmable really at all.
But we'd give them advice at how to use it and things like that. I think they're good machines. They have a lot of power, but they're antiquated with their program.
It's seriously antiquated with the program. But so I, you know, really pushed people to a true rif because you could program it.
Now, the atelier rabid and the true rif are equal in their programming ability.
The atelier rabid is superior in that you can do higher frequencies. You can do 11th harmonic frequencies and there's some other things coming down the road.
Now, true rif, Jake, a true rif is said that they're going to upgrade to a new machine.
You told me that this summer, I don't know when that's coming out.
But it's a completely new machine that would, that would enable some of these things. I don't know what else he didn't give me.
He clues what is going to be enabled on that new board that they're going to have for this new machine. And I can't remember what he told me they're going to call it.
It would require a person to buy the new machine. So, I mean, you were going to buy a second machine and buy the atelier rabid.
If you're like, I already, I can afford a second machine. I just want the best. Should I, you know, sell my true rif and buy an atelier rabid?
No, I don't know. I would say no. You know, all my staff and the true rif, all my family still has the true rif, that they're great machines.
It's just like, if you came to me and said, I want to get a second one, then I'd say, look at the atelier rabid. You'll have the best of both ones.
The negative the atelier rabid, it's a little bigger. It's not going to be as easy to travel with if you're traveling a lot. So that is a negative at the atelier rabid.
And we still are working out some bugs with it. So, but, you know, I'm, I'd still, I think it's the better machine.
Can you read the Meyer's mental testing results?
I, you can send them to me. I don't know what they are. So if they're a hair analysis test or a blood test or a saliva test, definitely send them to lambs at cutters.
C O N E R S clinic dot com. And I can look at them as you can set up on a point. We can talk about it.
Are there other reasons for tumor markers to increase other than cancer?
So, we don't really know. So remember, tumor markers have a normal range. Okay.
So, let's use CA 153. That's really you typically only found in in breast cancer.
I think the range is 0 to 33 or 0 to 35 or something like that. I could be wrong, but that's about the range and CA 153.
So let's say yours is 15. Let's say normal range. Well, where's that coming from? So where is that 15 coming from?
And I don't know if it's 15 what right in that blood sample that was taken. Yes. So yes, other cells give off two of our cars. They're not specific to cancer only.
So yes, other cells can give that off. And there's not.
So when they were first discovered, there's a lot of hype about them and I talked about this before.
But because they're elevated when somebody does chemotherapy, then, you know, there's been, you know, the.
It's kind of gone on the poo poo list for oncologists to do because then they have to talk people, you know, off the ledge when their tumor markers go up when they're doing chemotherapy.
As you know, a couple of mine were trading up a bit, but we're not considered on a range. However, even before my surgeries, they were lower than they are now FYI have one of those whole body MRI scheduled after Christmas.
Oh, great. The next week they do a console for the radio is to interpret the results that we schedule it to that's going to be exciting to see what that is.
So I know that we had another patient on a few months ago that after his colo rectal surgery is colon surgery, I think it's just to a marker go upward at his.
His circulated tumor cell marker I think was that went up and was not going down.
And I do I don't couldn't find any data on that.
So hair test that's the metal test, certainly you can look at that. I again, I don't put a lot of stock in those hair analysis tests, but we can certainly look at it does give us like any other test.
It just gives us clues.
So yeah, which you can send it any any other questions. So remember with what YouTube is doing to us these will these recordings will be up on our video channel and the data.
Where to find that video channel is videos dot cutters clinic dot com, but the URL specifically is up on our member site.
So and we may end up just moving away completely from YouTube because they're probably going to take down our whole channel.
And your time your things would get better, but they just don't seem to get better. So.
And then I'll post if I'm going to do the I think I'm going to do the zoom call on.
Do your stay, which is the following Wednesday, not X Wednesday, but the following.
Just so we don't miss two weeks.
Everybody have a very blessed Christmas. If I don't talk to you before that, enjoy your family and know that we're praying for you.
Alright, bye bye.